[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg
guten Abend ihnen allen Rudi Zahne ist
auch dabei für den Sport hallo schönen
guten Abend und das sind die Nachrichten
Themen dieses Sonntags
der Kanzler im sommer-interview Olaf
Scholz verteidigt den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland und will
die Lieferung neuer Waffensysteme an die
Ukraine sorgsam prüfen
Italien immer mehr unter Druck fast
1.000 Flüchtlinge und Migranten gehen
allein an diesem Wochenende auf
Lampedusa an Land
und Dämpfer im Supercup Finale Bayern
München verliert überraschend klar gegen
RB Leipzig trotz Hurricane
[Musik]
der Bundeskanzler hat derzeit viele
Großbaustellen das Land echt immer noch
unter steigenden Preisen es fehlen
Wohnungen und Fachkräfte bei
klimaschutzbildung Pflege
Digitalisierung liegt einiges im Arten
und das Deutschland beim
Wirtschaftswachstum vergleichsweise
schlecht da steht ist so meint die
Mehrheit im ZDF Politbarometer extra die
Schuld der Bundesregierung der Kanzler
gibt sich im ZDF sommerinterview
trotzdem gelassen Andreas
als Olaf Scholz zu seinem zweiten
zdf-sommer-interview als Bundeskanzler
kommt ist sein Ansehen deutlich
schlechter als beim ersten eigens
nachgemessen in einem Politbarometer
extra Bundeskanzler Scholz setzt sich in
wichtigen politischen Fragen eher durch
sagen nur 21 Prozent er nicht durch
sagen
73%. erstmal ist die Diagnose nicht
zutreffend wir haben sehr viele sehr
konkrete Entscheidungen getroffen ich
wünschte mir dass das im Ton manchmal
anders stattfindet als es in der
Vergangenheit war und habe auch den
Eindruck dass über den Sommer sich viele
vorgenommen haben das genau zu ändern
Kritik an seiner Wirtschaftspolitik
weist Scholz zurück wegen des niedrigen
Wachstums der hohen Strompreise und der
fehlenden Fachkräfte warnen die
Wirtschaftsverbände vor Abwanderung ins
Ausland und das
ärgert mich auch in jedem
volkswirtschaftskurs lernen die
Studenten und Studenten dass der Erfolg
einer Volkswirtschaft darin gesehen
werden kann dass ihre Unternehmen auch
im Ausland investieren nun muss ich ab
und zu hören und lesen dass das
angeblich schlecht sind aber ist gut in
der Asylpolitik kündigt nun auch der
Kanzler an die abschieberegeln zu
verschärfen und stellt sich damit klar
hinter den Vorschlag von Innenministerin
faesar keine Antwort gibt Scholz auf die
Frage ob Deutschland der Ukraine
Marschflugkörper vom Typ Taurus liefern
wird die Bürger finden das richtig dass
nicht jedes Mal wenn einer irgendwo in
einer
irgendwo in einem Gesprächen fragt und
sagt das noch das noch dann immer gleich
gesagt und ja sondern dass wir uns
schwer machen wir werden es uns weiter
schwer machen der Kanzler machte sich
schwer so Scholz Fazit im Sommer
Interview in Potsdam aber er mache alles
richtig
das komplette sommerinterview mit dem
Bundeskanzler können Sie direkt nach uns
sehen wo ist die Kritik an der Regierung
besonders groß welche Themen sind den
Befragten wichtig auch dazu empfehlen
wir das Politbarometer extra nachzulesen
in der ZDF heute App
bei einem russischen Artillerieangriff
in der Region herson sind sieben
Menschen ums Leben gekommen darunter
eine Familie mit zwei Kindern der
deutsche Rüstungskonzern reinmetall
kündigte heute an bald auch Drohnen in
die Ukraine zu liefern es handelt sich
um aufklärungsdrohnen vom Typ Luna ng
die mehrere hundert Kilometer weit
fliegen können der Auftrag kommt von der
Bundesregierung
immer mehr Menschen versuchen illegal in
die EU einzureisen so viele wie seit
2016 nicht mehr die Grenzschutzagentur
Frontex registrierte in diesem Jahr
schon mehr als
176.000 unerlaubte Grenzübertritte die
meisten davon gut 89.000 kommen übers
Mittelmeer die italienische Insel
Lampedusa erreichten allein an diesem
Wochenende rund 1.000 Menschen Annette
hilsenbeck berichtet auf kleinen
überfüllten botenwagen die Migranten die
Fahrt alleine 27 solcher Backen waren es
gestern die übers Mittelmeer kamen auch
die italienische küstenbar brachte
Menschen an Land das Durchgangslager auf
Lampedusa für etwa 400 Menschen gebaut
mit etwa 2000 Migranten überfüllt so wie
oft in diesem Jahr
schon seit Januar verzeichnen wir
unglaublich hohe Zahlen so viel dass die
gesamte Aufnahme und hilfsmaschine die
enorme Anstrengung machen musste wir
haben nun die italienische Regierung
erneut um Hilfe
Küstenwache und private
Hilfsorganisationen sind im Dauereinsatz
trotzdem nur vier Menschen überlebten
vor wenigen Tagen als ein Boot kennterte
41 Insassen kamen ums Leben viele der
Flüchtlinge stammen aus zentral- oder
Westafrika sie sind in Tunesien
losgefahren wo die geschwächte Regierung
in einer Krise steckt in Tunesien hat
sich eine Situation hergestellt als
Alternative zu leben wo die Europäische
Union in Italien seit Jahren Hunderte
Millionen von Euro reingepumpt haben
damit diese zwangsweise Rückführung nach
Libyen stattfinden kann immer wieder
werden Flüchtlinge vom Lager auf
Lampedusa zum Festland gebracht doch
Italiens Behörden rechnen damit dass die
Situation sich nicht verändert schon
jetzt ist die Zahl der Ankünfte mehr als
doppelt so hoch wie im Vorjahr
auf der Hawaii-Insel Maui steigt die
Zahl der Opfer nach den Bränden weiter
93 Tote sind jetzt bestätigt aber
Hunderte von Menschen werden noch
vermisst nach Angaben des
polizeischiffes konnte bisher nur ein
kleiner Teil des katastrophengebiets
abgesucht werden die Rückkehr finden
ihre die Rückkehrer finden ihre Heimat
in Asche und Ruinen David sauer
mit dem Fahrrad fährt Amazon Timmons die
Straße ab 18 Jahre war das seine
Nachbarschaft
die ganzen Restaurants die gibt es
einfach nicht mehr
der Hafen
die Promenade das alles war mal
die Autos der flüchtenden stauten sich
an der Uferstraße als die Flammen kamen
sich aber nur im Meer
ich saß oben auf meinem Dach und kämpfte
gegen die Brände drei Stunden bis ich
nicht mehr konnte ich musste weg dann
sprang ich ins Meer musste aufgeben
Aufnahmen aus der entfernungnacht diese
Menschen müssen zusehen wie ihre Heimat
in Flammen untergeht der Rauch raubt
ihnen den Atem
tagsüber durchforsten jetzt Suchtrupps
die Aschewüste markieren was abgesucht
wurde viele Leichen seien so stark
verkohlt dass sie sich auflösen wenn sie
geborgen werden angehörige sollen
deshalb DNA Proben einreichen online
Posten viele Fotos von vermissten es
sollen noch hunderte sein die Stufen zu
Kohle stehen noch mehr nicht er fragt
warum blieben die Sirenen stumm
mein Telefon hat einmal gepiepst als ich
ins Auto stieg das war die einzige
Warnung völlig nutzlos
an der Zufahrtstraße nach einer warten
viele auf Einlass sie wollen nach
Angehörigen oder Haustieren suchen und
die Ruinen ihrer Häuser sehen
ein wichtiger Gedenktag heute vor genau
62 Jahren begann der Bau der Berliner
Mauer mit Kranz niederlegungen an der
Gedenkstätte Bernauer Straße wurde der
Opfer gedacht mit der Mauer riegelte die
DDR ab 1961 die Grenze zu Westberlin ab
die deutsch-deutsche Teilung war damit
besiegelt bis zur Öffnung 1989 starben
mindestens 140 Menschen bei ihren
Fluchtversuchen dort
viele Brücken hierzulande sind marode
und müssen ersetzt werden das galt auch
für eine der wichtigsten Autobahnbrücken
im Rhein-Main-Gebiet nach zehn Jahren
Bauzeit und vielen Staus ist das
Großprojekt zwischen Mainz und Wiesbaden
jetzt fertig heute wurde die neue
Schiersteiner Brücke eingeweiht ab
morgen kann der Verkehr dann erstmals
komplett über die Doppelbrücke rollen
jetzt Fußball Bayern München war gestern
ziemlich enttäuscht ja kann man so sagen
für Bayerns Trainer Thomas Tuchel war
die 0 zu 3 Niederlage im Supercup
wörtlich erschreckend den ersten Titel
der Saison schnappt sich RB Leipzig nach
einer überzeugenden Vorstellung trotz
der Enttäuschung nach einem Kurzeinsatz
sprach der neue Star Harry Kane von
einer magischen Nacht in München
der fußballerische Höhepunkt des Spiels
in der 44 Minute Leipzig Stani Olmo
artistisch zum 2:0 der spanische
Nationalspieler hatte sein Team schon
nach drei Minuten in Führung geschossen
damit eine so nicht erwartete
superkapati eingeleitet in der 63 die
umjubelte Einwechslung von Bayern
Neuzugang Harry Kane der dann nur drei
Ballkontakte hat nicht den Szene gesetzt
werden kann Trainer Tuchel entschuldigt
sich der denkt wahrscheinlich
dass wir vier Wochen nicht funktioniert
haben
deshalb war er für ihn tut's mir am
meisten Leid der Rest schnell erzählt
dann die Olmo erzählt per Elfmeter den
3:0 entstand drei Tore dreimal Almo der
Spielball soll bei ihm einen besonderen
Platz bekommen
ein Überblick über die Ergebnisse von
DFB-Pokal heute Nachmittag
Unterhaching wird erst legist Augsburg
in der ersten Runde aus dem Wettbewerb
der HSV gewinnt 4:3 bei Rot-Weiß Essen
durch einen Treffer 3 Minuten vor Ende
der Verlängerung außerdem Rostocker fC
Heidenheim 08 Lok Leipzig Eintracht
Frankfurt 07
Oberachern SC Freiburg 02 TuS makabi
Wolfsburg 06 Rot-Weiß Koblenz
Kaiserslautern 05 und Illertissen
Fortuna Düsseldorf 1:3
Zusammenfassungen von den
dfb-pokalspielen finden Sie in der ZDF
heute App
Dirk Nowitzki ist die größte Ehre zu
teil geworden die einen Basketballer in
den USA erfahren kann der 45 Jahre alte
Würzburger ist in die Hall of Fame die
Ruhmeshalle seine Sports aufgenommen
worden Nowitzki spielte 21 Jahre so
lange wie kein anderer Profi in den USA
für denselben Club die Dallas Mavericks
Höhepunkt war die erste und einzige
Meisterschaft der Texaner 2011 mit dem
wertvollsten Spieler der Finalserie
nämlich Dirk Nowitzki
hat er seine ganze Familie mitgebracht
ja so soll das sein fehlt noch der Blick
aufs Wetter zunächst vom Saarland bis
nach Sachsen Schauer und heilskräftige
Gewitter nachmittags auch im Süden sonst
oft freundlich im Südosten heiß bei 24
bis 33 Grad das war es von uns um 9:45
Journal wir sagen danke und tschüss hier
geht's weiter mit dem ZDF
sommerinterview mit dem Bundeskanzler
und theol